Hi, I'm Phil Sly.
I'm the pastor of Discipleship and Community here at Henderson Hills,
and we're looking at community group certification.
We've looked at different roles, the role of the Bible teacher and the director,
and the prayer and care coordinator. Well,
tonight we're going to look at a key leader who's often unsung and humble,
yet plays a very significant role in the spiritual growth and the outreach of
the community group.
And this unsung hero is none other than an outreach and social leader. Now,
this role goes far beyond just organizing social groups or events or
programs. Uh,
this leader becomes the driving force by about fulfilling the great commission.
They lead the mandate given to all believers by Jesus Christ himself.
And so we're gonna explore the importance of the social outreach leader in a
community group context by, uh,
drawing inspiration from both Matthew 28 19 and 20, and Acts one, eight.
So let's look at the outreach Social Leaders Great commission. Uh, the, uh,
great Commission is a call to reach people for Christ.
And so before diving into the role of the outreach leader,
it's essential that we understand the origin of this mission.
In Matthew 28, 19 and 20,
it encapsulates the mandate where Jesus instructs his disciples
to go, make disciples of all nations, baptizing them in the name of the Father,
son of the Holy Spirit, and teaching them to obey everything I've commanded you.
This commandment is known as the Great Commission,
and it extends to all believers,
and it serves literally as the cornerstone of Christian faith and living.
And so, uh, community groups,
were gonna play a significant role in fulfilling the Great Commission.
This is not the the staff's responsibility. This is not the, uh,
comms department's responsibility. This is all of our responsibility.
And so by inviting new members, uh,
into the community group at their events and at their socials,
they have an opportunity to intentionally connect with them and eventually teach
them about Jesus and the gospel so that they can come to know him and then maybe
grow in their faith. And so, uh, this is the Outreach Leader's Purpose.
An outreach leader embodies the,
in the essence of the Great Commission and serves as a bridge between,
uh, the, the community group and the world, uh, outside of the church walls.
And so their primary purpose as a, uh,
outreach social leader is to inspire and equip and mobilize fellow
believers to engage in evangelism and discipleship.
So here's some crucial aspects of their role. First one, spiritual leadership.
The outreach leader must exhibit a deep and authentic relationship of Christ.
They model the virtues of love and compassion and empathy.
Their life then becomes a living testimony of God's grace and serves
as an inspiration for others to follow. Ultimately, the community group should,
uh, learn through the example
Of this leader to create experiences and ultimately a multiplying
effect as these believers grow in their faith,
as they develop leadership strengths and experiences.
And then they go on to start new community groups because there's just not space
in the group where you're community group is meeting. Uh,
so that's spiritual leadership. Number two, organizing outreach socials.
An effective outreach social leader designs and coordinates various outreach
socials. Now,
this is a philosophical change in just a regular community group event.
Many community group events are created just so that people who know one another
can hang out together.
But what I'm asking you to do is to make those social events actual outreach
events,
to see that the community group mobilizes to invite people to their social
events that are outside of the group, neighbors and friends, maybe ball team,
parents, coworkers.
They're inviting people so that they can come inside from
outside and meet people within the community group,
whether they've ever been to the church or not. Uh, number three,
purpose is equipping the saints. Equipping the,
the community group for outreach is a significant aspect of the outreach
social leader, uh,
through talking and celebrating and mentorship and outreach opportunities,
they help community group members gain confidence in sharing their faith with
others and nurturing brand new disciples. Uh, d uh,
fostering a culture of reaching. This is so important for community groups,
especially those that are meeting, been meeting for a number of years. Uh,
the social outreach leader actively works to create a culture of
growth, of reaching, of evangelism, of living scent within the community group.
This involves encouraging open conversations about faith at these events.
It's,
it's about providing resources for personal evangelism and celebrating
stories of transformed lives. Uh, we used to call 'em testimonies,
but these are faith stories of how God has changed someone's life through a
relationship with Jesus. So,
community groups must develop a culture of vision that motivates them to reach
people for Christ.
They're better equipped to reach people for Christ than any other organization
in the church. Uh,
did you know community groups is Henderson Hill's largest organization,
and we meet all the time. We meet Sunday at nine, at 10 30,
at 5:00 PM Monday night at six 30, Wednesday nights at six 15. And,
uh,
these community groups can be organized effectively to quickly assimilate new
people and build new relationships. It happens every week. So, uh,
that's creating or fostering a culture of reaching. And so, uh,
a social outreach leader, uh, number two, we talked about Acts one,
eight is empowered by the Holy Spirit to comprehend how this is going
to happen.
This vast sweep of a social outreach leader's role,
we have to turn to Acts one, eight, where Jesus says,
you will receive power when the Holy Spirit comes upon you,
and you'll be my witnesses in Jerusalem, Judea, Samaria,
and the ends of the earth.
So the Holy Spirit empowers believers to become bold witnesses
of the gospel. And an outreach leader,
outreach social leader plays a vital role in helping people discover and
utilize this Holy Spirit power. Uh,
one eight's also a reminder that our responsibility as a community group extends
beyond our intermediate, our immediate circle. Uh,
we're called to be witnesses to the ends of the earth,
sharing the good news of Jesus with all who will listen. So, uh,
community groups are, uh,
play a vital role in fulfilling this call to become God's witnesses.
And they do that by bringing new members from diverse backgrounds who all have
an opportunity to share the gospel with the people who are in that group.
And some may have never heard it before.
And this can be especially true about community groups that are intentional
about outreach and evangelism. And so,
as a community group welcomes new members,
they're expanding their reach and fulfilling their call to be witnesses to the
end of the earth.
The last thing I wanna talk to you about is the social outreach leader.
As a catalyst of transformation,
an effective outreach social leader becomes a catalyst for spiritual
transformation in both the community group and the church.
They facilitate this in several ways. First of all,
personal transformation by encouraging believers to actively participate in
outreach efforts.
The social outreach leader fosters personal growth and spiritual maturity in the
manner of Christ who is always, uh,
going to those who are not a part of the inner circle.
They engage in evangelism and,
and discipleship and provide opportunities for people within their community
group to step outside their comfort zone and rely on the Holy Spirit's power.
So that's personal transformation, but there's also unity and fellowship.
What that means is that outreach initiatives bring the community group together
for a shared purpose.
I've seen this happen where a community group plans a social event.
This was a Christmas party, and I know community groups have Christmas parties,
but they made this an intentional outreach event. And one lady, uh,
asked for prayer for her husband who she knew was not a believer.
He never comes to church. He doesn't support me in my spiritual efforts,
but I know I can get him to come to the Christmas party. And so, uh,
we as a community group begin to pray for this lady's husband.
And what happened on that night, he shows up.
And so now it's more than a Christmas party.
It's an opportunity to lead this lady's husbands to Jesus.
And long story short, he did start attending the community group,
and he did place his faith in Christ. And so, uh,
believers who work hand in hand to reach others,
they strengthen their bonds one to another,
and they create a tightly knit community of faith with a purpose for reaching
people for Jesus. And then next is the impact on the community.
A dedicated outreach leader can significantly impact the community group by
addressing various needs such as loneliness and spiritual emptiness.
Uh, in my lifetime, and I'm on the older side of,
of adulthood in my lifetime,
I've never seen the culture as lonely as they are as a result of C O V I D.
And as a result of a a working from home,
there are so many people that have reported just a epic, um,
an epidemic of loneliness.
And we have an opportunity to extend what God has given us beyond the walls of
the church and spread the message of hope and love to those who are loneliest,
who need it the most. And, uh,
what I want you to to understand is in the economy of God, uh,
leading out, uh, leading out an outreach comes with both challenges,
but also with rewards. Yes,
there will be periods of discouragement as the, you may as a leader,
face resistance. And we just wanna have a party.
We don't wanna invite a bunch of people. Well,
that's not the purpose of the church. And so yeah,
you might res face some resistance, but there will also be rewards and,
uh, rewards for your labor. Uh, listen to this, uh,
witnessing results in transformed lives, hearts turning to Christ,
commitments to experience Christ's love and restoration.
These are immeasurable, invaluable rewards. And, uh,
and I wanna just go on record as saying that of all the roles reaching people
for Christ and the purpose of the community group,
this is the highest purpose of Christian community. Um,
the social outreach leader is the,
is the catalyst for helping the community group understand its role in growth
and evangelism.
And through their spiritual leadership and dedication in organization,
they can equip and empower fellow believers in the community group to become
effective witnesses of Christ's love.
And inspired by Christ and inspired by the, inspired by the Biblical ma, uh,
models in scripture and the empowerment of the Holy Spirit,
the social outreach leader literally becomes an agent of transformation and
impacts both the community group and the church overall.
And so my prayer is that at Henderson Hills,
we would strive to become a beacon of light in a dark world and world.
And the role of the community group outreach leader remains of utmost importance
because they uphold the very essence of Christianity.
And that is to go and make disciples of all nations.